do you find that there's still still a
stigma being attached
to this brand of teen mom when you're
you know nearly a 30 year old woman and
a successful wife and a successful
parent to
almost four kids i think a lot of people
still consider or think of us as being
these young or teen moms did you see the
one where someone
said to keep my legs closed or something
i was like
i mean i'm married so it just cracks me
up
of course everybody is gearing up for
this season
10 premiere of team um two how are you
feeling about it i always get so nervous
because
to me like i live it and we film it and
then
now when it's about to air i'm like oh
my god what did we film
and then it's like oh wait now it's
gonna be out there in front of all these
people so
it's a little bit i'm like okay what is
it but it's gonna be good
well i i think the big news that we owe
you a huge congratulations on
is your pregnancy child number four is
on the water
how i mean when you hear that out loud
how does that make you
i mean when i hear it or i say it
it's it's still so crazy i'm in the
beginning of the second trimester
i am feeling pretty good i have
definitely been shocked because
having three babies before this you i
mean i felt like
i know what it's gonna be like like i
got this handled but no
it's totally different this time like i
feel different
so i don't ever know i feel like i was a
little bit more sicker
um my body just kind of hurts all around
it's like okay we're on fourth we know
what to do
like it's stretching and everything's
moving around earlier
but i mean it's good and there's nothing
really bad so i'm very fortunate
can we get a little shot of the bump
okay yeah here it
is oh my gosh so beautiful it's little
it's little but it's definitely there
do you think your family is complete at
this point
or i mean sky's the limit are you gonna
keep expanding
well as of right now i feel like this
baby's gonna complete our
family but i mean who knows like
in five years maybe we'll get a wild
hair but as of right now it feels like
complete love it this is a
situation probably is this gonna be
something we have to go to court again
what can you share with us what are we
going to see this season
there's a lot of aubry time this season
and
just like expanding i did a lot with
lori bells and
lily and lonnie the clothing line which
has been incredible i was just really
like finding me
and i was kind of getting into the flow
of how to juggle everything
um and balance everything and then
that's when
you know corona hit and everything got
put to halt
this season aubrey is very much like a
preteen now like she is getting
more mature she like want her own cell
phone which
brings her that own issues because
that having a cell phone kind of puts a
bridge
in between um her other family and us
and so it was kind of hard to navigate
that and do what's best there
what was the issue with that well there
was no issues it was just like what's
gonna be
best for her like free range like she
can talk to
her dad whenever or is he gonna reach
out to her or not like i just want to
protect
her heart always of course a huge part
of your of your family and your journey
is
watching you navigate you know that that
delicate balance between
omri life with the divorce and then
aubrey's life with
her dad's side of the family yes where
does the relationship stand today how
are things
i think we've reached a good place and
hopefully it stays that way
yeah but so far things are good i think
everyone's comfortable with
kind of what we have going now i mean
it's taken you nearly 11 years to get it
all
so please please let this be good right
what is the setup right now so right now
if she would like to go visit
his family she's able to do so she does
have to communicate with them
um when she wants to um but it's kind of
more um up to aubrey a little bit more
it's not just like you have to go here
and here on these dates
you know what i mean it's it's like if
she wants to go visit
family members she can and it's a little
bit more free-flowing
where does aubry's heart lie does she
actively like love going to spend time
with dad like how does she feel about
everything
well and even with the agreement that we
have it's not really spending time with
him it's
it's usually his parents or it's his
parents
so but she she enjoys going over there i
think
you know just as if she visits my
parents
when was the last time she saw her dad
she did do softball this summer and he
was at a few games
so she was able to see him there that's
special i'm sure that meant a lot
oh yes it's so cool that you and cole
are in this amazing process
of building your dream home and now that
you're
three almost four kids in it really begs
the question chelsea i mean are there
conversations about doing a spin-off
series
i mean if it was the right spin-off
series we
would love to we have enjoyed this
building process and the whole home
process
so much it's been so much fun to be like
flipping farm houses
or like anything to do with home stuff
and it wasn't so focused on like
personal deep things like a super light
and fun thing
i think we would absolutely love that we
have watched you
on tv for the last decade when you think
back on on all these years is there
anything that you would have done
different or you would have changed
about your experience
being on the other side of kind of all
the heartbreak and all the negativity
and stuff
i don't regret that you know now i can
say i can see i love to be able to see
from the beginning
you know the lows and the highs
is aubrey allowed to watch the show does
she no she's not because she's never she
doesn't i don't even think she wants to
like there's
she'll randomly say commercial or
something but she's not like i want to
watch the show and we have to be like no
you can't
obviously being her mom i'd want to
protect her from anything negative that
you know her dad ever did or said yeah
um
but there's a moment in there oh there's
some
extremely painful moments um
and i'm sure it's gonna come up
eventually and i am well aware of that
i think i'm just waiting until that
happens and then i'm gonna have to
figure it out
10 years on this show how will you know
when it's the right time
to walk away i don't know i'm i'm
honestly
just gonna go with my gut if it's not
feeling right
um i feel like i'm i'm learning to do
that more like to go with my gut and
trust
how i'm feeling so it's been so
good these last few years especially
that i mean i'm just i really enjoy the
people that we work with
and um everything that it would be hard
to walk away
um so i'm just gonna just go with my gut
i guess
i think it's pretty wild that we first
met you i think when you were 17
do you find that there's still still a
stigma being attached
to this brand of teen mom when you're
you know
nearly a 30 year old woman and a
successful wife and a successful parent
to almost four kids
i think a lot of people still consider
or think of us as being
these young or teen moms did you see the
one where someone
said to keep my legs closed or something
i was like
i mean i'm married so it just cracks me
up people just don't
realize that we are almost 30 i don't
think and married and
you know we're not teenagers anymore
right okay so
do you find that the the label of the
show has been detrimental to you in any
way
no i don't think so besides like the
here and there negative comments
i don't think so i just have to pay you
a huge compliment you know
you have always been all class i don't
know if you ever read the comments on
like the youtube videos but everybody is
just
so impressed by the fact that you just
want to be a mom
you just want to do what's right for
your kids you've never cared about
drama or anything um nasty you just love
your family so how have you avoided the
the drama and maybe the pitfalls that
come with
um you know becoming a parent at such an
early age in life
i feel like when when i had my daughter
so young and i was gonna be on the tv
show
it was either i can be the stereotypical
or whatever
anyone thinks of a young mom and
or i could prove them wrong you know and
even if i didn't have the show like i
did
i wanted to go above and beyond and
prove people wrong and
i do i've always wanted to be a mom this
is like what i always wanted in life and
i get so overwhelmed with drama that i
i know to just distance myself and not
be a part of it otherwise
i'm like one of those people that if i
get too overwhelmed or it's too much i
just cry
so i'm like i don't want to cry so i'm
just going to stay on it
you have just really glowed up we have
watched you
you know transform into this gorgeous
redhead when we first met you
you looked quite different um what is it
about this like
health transformation you've gone
through and you've experimented with
your look
um talk to me a little bit about that
and how do you feel when you see old
photos or old footage
i i honestly it i can't i can't
i don't like to look at it i feel like
um
there was a time when i was growing up i
really experimented a lot
trying to find myself once i started
taking really good care of myself and
eating healthier and working out and
just
finding myself then i realized i felt a
lot more comfortable
in my skin um i mean
i definitely don't like looking back at
some of those seasons i'm not gonna lie
what what is it that irks you or makes
you cringe
oh my god so many like obviously the
blonde
stage probably my least favorite even
just like looking back at when i was so
young like the eyebrows like the thin
thin eyebrows
but i guess i was a victim too
oh my god i just i i don't know it is
what it is but
if i if i can avoid watching that stuff
i definitely do
or like when an article some of the
articles
they'll attach a picture and they'll
attach like an old picture i'm like
no i'm not gonna retweet that i'm not
sure i'm doing that
send us a current press photo yes get us
a current photo